to what degree is money going to decide
the outcome if it is then they're going
to win so I don't think it's going to
decide the outcome the truth of the
matter is that money makes a lot of
difference in politics and the way our
rules are set up is distorting and you
know it's it's a scary thing and for our
democracy but the other thing that's
true is a mere I think people are
forgotten Americans are smart we totally
believe that 300 million Americans are
smarter than anybody you know the old
saying Americans always do the right
thing after they try everything else but
by the way are really smiling church oh
and the information gets to Americans
they're really brave and they're really
smart and we do the right not to be too
lofty about it but that is the central
bet that was made by the founding
fathers yeah we actually trust people to
make the decision and it was a crazy
idea what okay twas come up with so we
were trust everybody get together decide
that was the central underlying theme of
this Republic look one man one woman one
vote okay but with all the money in
campaign finance it is completely out of
whack because that information getting
to all of those Americans is coming at
hyper speed because of all the money
these candidates have there is surly and
Ryan obfuscated here but I think over
time Americans see through it they're
really smart we will come to the right
decision we will lead the world on this
this is gonna turn out to be at abs this
is the generational challenge and I
don't believe Americans turned down the
generational challenge for you that
right decision is Hillary Clinton haha
we what we've been saying in 2015 is we
want we are asking every candidate to
come up with a plan to show us how we
get to fifty percent clean energy by
2030 including mrs. Clinton has anyone
done it I'd say all of the Democrats
have said we're committed to this no one
has come out with a fully detailed plan
but it's also early in the election